comme chaque vendredi des idées de
sorties dans la région c'est l'agenda
culturel de mélanie trash l'air avec
d'abord un coup de projecteur sur l'
orchestre du coin qui dévoilera demain à
saint pierre des corps un nouvel album
les images sont signés tafi tchouga leur
castres du coin vient de sortir un
sixième cd il s'appelle populus nile
beat et ça pulse écouter
il est par ailleurs
leur répertoire va du swing et à
l'afrobeat en passant par les danses de
salon et la techno un style décalé
normal ils font partie de la compagnie
de coin créée il ya 16 ans à tours
dans le collectif la compagnie du coin
il y a il ya donc ces deux formations
phares qui existe depuis le début
quasiment mais deux et qui propose des
choses différentes
et
j'ai toujours été une préoccupation de
faire danser les gens aient eu un
répertoire de musette en 2003 il ya eu
du spike jones ait eu des choses très
très enlevée dans le tempo et il ya deux
ans on a eu envie de faire répertoire
qu'on compose tous ensemble concrètes
hausse ensemble et qui s'appelle maupeou
le style
le groupe prévoit de sortir un 45 tours
l'été prochain en attendant vous pourrez
swing et dès demain soir à saint pierre
des corps pour l'inauguration du point
haut en plus c'est une soirée gratuite
dessins céramiques masquer les
installations vidéo de cécile ravel
prennent le spectateur à partie pour
mieux le perdre c'est l'été dans la
forêt un moment de plénitude éphémère à
la chapelle sainte-anne animalité et
humanité entretiennent des relations
équivoques
l'exposition s'intitule somme allende et
durera jusqu'au 10 mai
par exemple je suis retrouvé devant ma
porte prétendants ces jeunes un van du
cap vert avec mayra andrade elle se
produira jeudi soir à saint jean de la
ruelle qui a récemment j'ai lu dans un
sondage que 80% des mares trompent leur
femme et damman jeudi que les sondages
c'est des conneries
tiens lever la part énergie qui trompent
leur femme
voilà pas un seul
et bien que les sondages c'est des
conneries et moi qui a vécu 15 ans vous
a su faire d'avoir un homme à la maison
en plus je trouve que c'est pas
compliqué de vivre en harmonie avec son
chéri et on referme cet agenda avec les
orléanais tesco et piper ils joueront à
l'astrolabe jeudi soir
l'agenda c'est terminé nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine avec de
nouvelles idées de sorties